la sorbonne une minute de silence pour
françois hollande
entouré de centaines de jeunes étudiants
une minute de silence observée dans
toute la france puis le président
français s'est rendu à versailles pour
s'adresser au congrès une rare assemblée
de tous les élus 577 députés 348
sénateurs
la france est en guerre les actes commis
vendredi soir à paris et près du stade
de france sont des actes de guerre le
président le répète depuis les attentats
de vendredi si le pays est en guerre ils
doivent se donner les moyens de se
battre
il demande aux élus de prolonger l'état
d'urgence de trois mois pour que les
forces de sécurité profite de ces
pouvoirs exceptionnels pour combattre
les islamistes radicaliser il réclame
aussi plus de pouvoirs pour le président
nous sommes en guerre mais cette guerre
d'un autre type face à l'adversaire
nouveau appel un régime constitutionnel
permettant de gérer l'état de crise il
veut que les élus amende la constitution
pour que le président puisse avoir les
mains libres pour intervenir en temps de
crise sans avoir évoqué l'état d'urgence
et la non sa création de milliers
d'emplois de policiers de garde
frontières de garder de prison il veut
faciliter la perte de citoyenneté
l'expulsion d'individus considérés comme
possibles terroristes
il veut que la communauté internationale
marche au même pas dans la lutte contre
le groupe armé islamique en oubliant
leurs désaccords dans d'autres dossiers
mais il faut un rassemblement de tous
ceux qui peuvent réellement lutter
contre cette armée terroriste dans le
cadre d'une grande et unique coalition
c'est à quoi nous travaillons c'est dans
cet esprit que je rencontrerai dans les
prochains jours le président obama et le
président poutine pour unir nos forces
et atteindre un résultat qui pour
l'instant est encore renvoyé à trop
longtemps
le discours devant le congrès se voulait
un symbole de solidarité de la nation
face à la terre les élus entonné en
choeur la marseillaise
à
c'était un discours attendu par un
peuple de france est plongée dans
l'insécurité
d'ailleurs bien des français n'ont pas
attendu l'exemple de leurs élus pour
démontrer leur solidarité face à la
terreur bravant l'interdiction de se
rassembler imposées par l'état d'urgence
c'est par milliers ils sont venus qu'ils
ont créée spontanément des lieux comme
ici des lieux de deuil de réflexion même
de prière sur les sites mènent des
attentats et c'est vraiment simple et
radio canada à paris